6 juin dernier la famille et les proches
de sophie lyonnais lui rendre un dernier
hommage à la cathédrale de sens ultime
décor d'un feuilleton qui aura duré neuf
mois
tout commence le 20 septembre 2010 est
ce jour là la police londonienne trouve
le corps calciné de sophie dionet au
domicile de ses employeurs
elle était jeune fille au pair depuis un
an et demi
six mois plus tard s'ouvre le procès de
ce couple franco algérien la famille de
sophie lyonnais fait le déplacement
depuis pas rond dans l'yonne
pendant huit longues semaines ils
découvriront le calvaire qu'a subi leur
fille entre les mains de sabrina kouider
et wissem ben meddou ni le couple
l'accusait de comploter contre eux ils
l'ont menacée torturé et l'avait même
filmé des images insoutenables pour la
famille lyonnais le 24 mai dernier le
verdict tombe
les employeurs de sophie lyonnais sont
reconnus coupables de son meurtre leur
peine sera prononcée le 26 juin
sabrina kouider et wissem médoune y sont
condamnés à la perpétuité